So, I think this was yesterday. Yesterday, the day before. Have
we been off this for two days? No. Yesterday, Destiny threw a
tweet up. He says, "Two huge rulings in my favor against at Pixie
Loves. Arbitrary, malicious, fraudulent lawsuit against me."
Um, I don't think it's arbit It's not arbitrary. It's by definition
not arbitrary. The most you could argue is malicious, it's not
fraudulent.
Uh, with some brutal commentary as well. Thank god. I don't know
if there's brutal commentary in here. Um,
what is he referring to here? This is Oh, is he misunderstand?
No, he he's not misunderstanding. He knows. We'll see. We'll
see when we get into it. But he's going to look at this and say,
"Oh, um, the judge was was mad at her for use for making this
statement." It's like, no,
no, this is showing her motivation for the lawsuit. Turns out
most civil suits cuz you want money. Somebody monetarily penalized
for some injury to you.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Okay. Receiving evidence of destruction of
evidence. Oh, they're going to call them out for like um we'll
get into each of these. I got to set it up first. So anyway,
Destiny says the lawsuit is malicious, fraudulent. There's a
lot of brutal commentary. Okay, that's one thing. He also went
to DG chat said some stuff about it. Okay, so two big denials.
Thank god. need to read them. But both preliminary injunction
and motion to compel KF got completely denied. Uh the motion
to compel KF to take down videos, that was just to get the the
video of Pixie, the the video that he leaked to a third party
taken down from KF. That's that's all that was. So it's kind
of telling that Destiny as a human being is like cheering for
that more or less. Like I think it's I think that's just very
funny to me that he's openly cheering for it. Why What am I missing?
Why is he celebrating KF not taking down the video? So, I think
part of that part of the reason he would be celebrating is because
I think I think Pixie's team put into their motion that they
wanted him to pay for those removals for like the law work the
legal work that went into getting those removals requested
and I so that's part of the reason he's celebrating here for
sure. I thought the injunction was Pixie's lawyer's demands to
take it down. Uh they did so in the preliminary injunction as
well. They said Destiny should be doing that himself. That's
one of the elements of the preliminary injunction that gets uh
struck down.
Okay,
keep reading. Oh my god, the judge is tech literate. They should
be on the court docket. No, so this would be him responding to
somebody. Oh my god, they got roasted in these. Are these public
yet? Oh my god, the judge sees through all of his Oh my god,
this pim injunction denial is so
Uh, it's very
Okay. Oh my god, it's so brutal. Oh, sorry. Okay, I'm done. She
herself so hard by being insane here.
Uh I don't think any of the stuff requested in the preliminary
injunction was insane,
right? So from this, you would think he like basically wins the
case off of um off of these denials, right? But the thing about
the preliminary injunction is it's seeking four different things.
Okay, the goals of the the preliminary injunction were four different
things. one,
stop him from
uh sharing, publishing, transmitting
any more videos of her, any more private messages of her, anything
like this. Okay, that was one. Two, compelling uh Destiny to
remove all publications of her private messages or any private
information about her from anywhere that he's done. So, right,
basically, stop talking about me. Remove anything you've done
talking about me. uh ordering destiny to cease and desist from
expoliation which is already something he has to do. So we expected
we expected one to be like reasonable possibly granted. I think
we expected 2 3 4 to probably not be granted because they had
to go through different avenues. I believe one and two are going
through a different avenue. And then three is already something
he had to do, something he was required to do.
And four is compelling Destiny to direct third parties to remove
any version of the video containing Pixie's likeness.
And that would be another motion as well. And that was denied.
I think um that one I think you would need a different motion
as well. So the thing about the preliminary injunction is is
you need to you need a preliminary injunction for the sake of
preventing irreparable harm.
And I think what this is going to come down to from my cursory
glance early on was that the judge basically believes that you
can go through the court in a at a regular speed for with individual
motions for all of the things remaining
and none of that will hurt you more than you've already been
harmed. So, like, well, while he's not saying none of this is
a harm, none of this is an injury. The judge is saying, "Okay,
you can just go through a normal court motion for all of these
things." So, she has normal court motions, I believe, for the
rest of the things already, if I'm not mistaken. Oh, uh, Ry,
you're linking me something. We can pull this up tomorrow. I
don't think I'm going to get to that stuff today. Yeah, I know
there's a whole other subpoena thing going on. I don't think
I'm going to get to it today, but we can go through these ones.
So, I think
I have to assume Pixie's team knew that the preliminary injunction
was going to be mostly or entirely denied, right? Shill. I have
shilled a bunch of times. Um I think the they knew they had to
have known because they already filed for the sake of preventing
Desty from discussing the case publicly a protective order motion,
right, which is still standing, hasn't been ruled on yet. So,
I think that's as we go through this, we'll see that the argument
the judge uses repeatedly is like there's no proof of an irreparable
harm being done that you need preliminary like injunctive relief
for. I think that's going to be the theme as we go through this,
but we'll we'll see. We do actually have to read the documents.
Okay, let's check out the motion to compel Kiwi Farms first.
I think we'll see how this one goes.
What do we got here? What do we got?
What do we got? Okay. USDC, Southern District of Florida, order
on plaintiff's motion for entry of order to compel of order to
compel LoCal LLC to remove videos. So, LoCal LLC is Kiwi
This is a thing saying, "Hey, Kiwi Farms, take my videos down."
Okay, here we go. Barrister outfit. Oh, shoot. That head's way
too big, though. What the What the What the There we go. There
we go. There we go. There we go. All right.
Oh, I need to update my title as well. One second. One second.
Okay, there we go. There we go.
This matter is before the court on plaintiff Jane Doe's motion
for the entry of agreed order to compel LCAL LLC to remove videos.
Documentary 80. Defendant timely responded documentary 83 to
which plaintiff timely replied documentary 94. Plaintiff also
filed on the docket a stipulation between plaintiff and nonparty
LCAL LLC Kiwi Farms regarding limited submission to jurisdiction.
Doc entry 93. Accordingly, plaintiff's motion is ripe for disposition.
After careful review of the motion, response, reply, relevant
authority, and for the reasons discussed below, plaintiff's motion
is denied.
One background. This case stems from the what the plaintiff alleges
is defendant's wrongful dissemination of a video of a nature.
The video involving both Ms. Doe and Mr.
Defendant, for his part, alleges that the situation was more
complex in that both plaintiff and defendant repeatedly shared
similar materials involving third parties with each other and
that practice in effect extended to other individuals. Documentary
42 at 8 denied. This would be the actual I wait, this would probably
be in response to the preliminary injunction, but it could also
refer to testimony from the evidentiary hearing they had.
It was then one of those individuals, Rose, whose Discord account
was allegedly hacked, which resulted in a leak of several videos
of a nature involving defendant, including the video uh previously
referenced at 9 documentary 421. So, it was then that he was
hacked and these videos were leaked online. Okay. The video in
the form that of what appears from plaintiff's proposed order
to be several iterations of uploads do entry 126 is now on a
multiplicity of websites hosting content of a nature. Among them,
Kiwi Farms, docket entry 120 at 4. While plaintiff alleges that
defendants's conduct caused the video to end up on Kiwi Farms
and other sites, documentary entry 94 at 7. The parties appear
to agree that defendant did not upload the video himself to Kiwi
Farms. See examples here, video solo tiny leaks, all this. So,
I think that's pretty easy to understand, right? The video is
originally uploaded remained live on KF from the time when it
was first uploaded until just after the lawsuit was filed. Documentary
81-2.
At that time, Kiwi Farms intervened to put the videos behind
a registration barrier, citing concerns about the impact on certain
individuals involved.
Previously cited at two, citing a letter uploaded to the Kiwi
Farm site by its custodian. But re-uploads of the video remain
on Kiwi Farms, and Plaintiff now asked the court to compel Kiwi
Farms to remove all those currently identified.
previously referenced one two plaintiff has garnered some cooperation
from Kiwi Farms in this endeavor in the form of a limited submission
to jurisdiction and reasonable understanding of what the site
is to do. Documentary 93 at 2 and 3. We were we to enter the
agreed proposed order documentary 80-1
uh redacted 126 unredacted still Kiwi Farms. Oh, so basically
what Kiwi Farms did here, what this is saying is Kiwi Farms said,
Josh Moon said, "Okay, if you guys can get a court order, we'll
take it down." Like, we don't want to just, you know, we don't
want to just respond to people saying, "Hey, take this down because
it's a free speech website. We want to anything legal under the
anything that's legally uploaded or even dubiously uploaded,
but like we feel is legal, we think we can keep up. So get a
court order telling us that we legally are required to and we'll
take it down for you.
Defendant for his part contends that not only would such an order
be futile because individuals can simply re-upload the video
a new but also that plaintiff's request is an injunction is an
injunction in motion to compel clothing and is thus impermissible
analysis.
We begin at the end which is to say by looking at what exactly
plaintiff is asking the court to order. The agreed proposed order
to which plaintiff repeatedly refers in her briefing seeks the
following. Loal LLC is hereby ordered to permanently remove from
its website Kiwi Farms the following URLs which contain or link
to a non-consentual intimate image video uh image/v video of
plaintiff. The proposed order then proceeds to list a number
of URLs that all begin with
because it bears on what plaintiff ultimately seeks. It merits
noting that the plaintiff's proposed order reflects a misunderstanding
about how URLs function. There is no permanent removal of a URL
from a website in the manner the proposed order seems to suggest.
A URL is basically a pathway to get somewhere on a given site.
Here kiwiarmms.net is the domain. The
to use a more common example. Then trailing that /threads is
a pathway within the site. For each of the URLs plaintiff lists,
what follows/threads
appears to be a unique identifier for each belonging to and thus
routing to an iteration of the video on the QARM site. In other
words, the URLs the URLs plaintiff lists are nothing more than
functions of how the site directs to stores and receives information.
A given URL itself cannot be permanently removed in the sense
she suggests.
Oh, I just assumed this was like I I get how this might sound
techsavvy
and yeah, you wouldn't prune like the URL, you would prune the
file, but it obviously points to a file, right? Like I I think
there's obviously some good faith interpretation there that says,
"Yeah, you would just remove the underlying media surfaced at
this URL."
Or maybe not. I don't know.
I It feels pretty obvious to me, but maybe not. You could, for
instance, reroute anyone trying to access a page, a specific
page back to the site's homepage or to a 404 not found page.
You could also delete information from a database so that a given
resource is no longer accessible. But in any event, the desired
manipulation would have to occur by way of underlying mechanics
of KF, a change that may or may not be reflected as contemplated
in the URL. Pliff's desired result is by its text misplaced.
Okay. They just didn't, I guess, identify what they needed removed
or what they wanted stripped correctly.
Interesting.
Additionally, and to the court's knowledge, while both parties
separately alleged that the video was uploaded to Kiwi Farms
without either of their consent, see examples, documentary 42
at 9, docu entry 120 at 45. Neither party is alleging that the
subject of the video itself or the recording thereof was without
consent. See examples, uh, docet entry 42 at 9, exhibit B, docket
entry 120 at 3.
Without further context, the statement that the following URLs
contain or link to a non-consensual intimate image/v video of
the plaintiff could well suggest different allegations than those
in the pleadings.
Oh, really? Okay. Okay. Okay. Oh, I see. So,
non-consensually it the language here is what they don't like.
So, it says a non-consensual intimate image. it there's an implication
that it is like um you know uh what would you call it like uh
like voyerism
right by the language it it sounds like it could be voyerism
and that's confusing I get it why are we even talking about all
this okay if it's a nonparty get to the point don't yell at me
that's the judge latigious gamer what are you talking about
how far are you from another hour we are 10 subs from another
two hours guys so you guys can sub you do whatever you like
we're we're looking
Um I will probably finish at least this document. So without
further context, so I think could well suggest different allegations
than those in the pleadings. For this and the reasons enumerated
above, plaintiff needs to be more specific with the relief she
requests of this court. Despite asking the court time and again
to refer specifically to the agreed proposed order, as the crux
of relief requested, documentary entry 80-1 reads as little more
than an afterthought. And even beyond the proposed order, plaintiff's
motion concludes in a similar fashion.
But in any event, plaintiffs plaintiff is ultimately asking the
court to force Kiwi Farms to take down or to take some kind of
action to either delete or otherwise make it inaccessible any
identified iterations of the video as enumerated in her proposed
order. Okay. Live fashions this request as one for entry of agreed
order to compel Loco LLC to remove videos. A quasi motion to
uh document entry 80 at one all caps omitted. We will proceed
to analyze it as such.
Okay. So he that is like so passive aggressive. That's like the
first three paragraph. No, the first like three pages of the
analysis are just him going, "Hey, you're kind of like annoying
me, but also
I'll I'll I'll interpret this in the obvious way. So now I'm
done ranting on
cool." I think I think that's funny most of the time. But hey,
I just wouldn't have read any of those paragraphs if I'd known
he's going to eventually go given all that, you know, I'll take
the obvious interpretation and I'll just rule like that. Okay,
thank you. Importantly, Kiwi Farms is not a party to this action.
No limited submission to jurisdiction changes the fact. Documentary
93 at 2. With good reason, the power of federal courts over such
nonparties is limited. Federal Rules of Civil Procedure 37 and
45 both regard situations where nonparties can be compelled to
participate in litigation. If the person is a nonparty, production
of documents can be compelled only by a subpoena. Deuces tekkum.
I don't know how to say this. Issued under I should figure that
out. Give me a second. How do we say that? How do we say it?
Okay. Can I get the pronunciation?
Thank you.
Ducy's tikum. Ducy's takum. Ducy's takum. Okay.
Ducy's tcum.
Issued under rule 45D1. The the purpose of rule 37 is to provide
the mechanism by which rules 26 and 36 can be made effective
is of limited application when applied to nonparties. It can
only be used to order a nonparty to answer written or oral and
oral questions under rules 30 and 31. It has no application to
nonparties refusal to produce documents.
or rule 37 moreover authorizes the basic motion for enforcing
discovery obligations and under which conditions including failures
under various other discovery related federal rules. Uh, section
2285, motion for order, compelling discovery
and general 8p.
Oh, federal practices and procedures civ. Oh my god, a bunch
of books. And federal rule 45 governing subpoenas to nonparties
regards the proper functioning of the discovery rules in instances
where a subpoena is necessary to compel someone who is not a
party to appear for the taking of a deposition or for the production
of various material things and electronic information.
Be clear. Rule 45 subpoena is a discovery vehicle to be used
against nonp parties to among other things obtain documents relevant
to a pending lawsuit. Okay. So basically because
uh because it's not being used to like further one of the questions
one of the I guess material facts of the case right it's like
agreed to then technically like trying to force this on nonparties
seems like unreasonable or not something that it's intended for.
That's that's what I'm getting out of this. If somebody has a
different interpretation, let me know. But plaintiff is not seeking
a deposition or information. Instead, she's asking us to issue
an order forcing a nonparty to take an action as to its own website,
its own business. By the necessity of what Kiwi Farms would have
to do because of such an order in some manner, removing or hiding
the identified iterations of the video, we'd only constru plaintiff's
motion as asking this court to issue an injunction requiring
Kiwi Farms to act. And that we cannot do. Courts of Equity have
long observed. So, they're just going to say that they cannot
do that. Thus it is axiatic that courts may only enjoin parties
before the court. So you cannot take injunctive relief. You cannot
enjoin somebody from some action unless they are party to the
lawsuit. So as somebody who's not party to the lawsuit, you cannot
be like stopped from speaking about a topic. You can't stop be
stopped from doing anything. Okay. To that end, federal rules
of civil procedure 65 is explicit as to the persons who may be
bound by an injunction. A the parties, B, the parties officers,
agents, servants, employees, and attorneys. and C other persons
who are inactive concert or participation with anyone described
in rule 65D2A
or B. We'll say this is probably A or B. So other persons who
are in active concert or participation with anyone described
here by A or B. I assume the parties or the party's officers
or agents.
But Kiwi Farms is neither a party nor an officer, agent, servant,
employee or attorney of either plaintiff or defendant. Ew Farms
is also not in active concert or participation with either plaintiff
or defendant. As for the defendant, he contends that a number
of his communications and explicit videos were published to a
website called Kiwi Farms and that he does not know who leaked
or uh leaked and unlawfully published his content online.
And as for plaintiff, notwithstanding any halfway cooperation
from Kiwi Farms on a proposed order, the very fact that plaintiff
is moving to force Kiwi Farms to in whatever manner revoke public
access to the video is inherently adversarial. Thus, nonparty
Kiwi Farms is beyond the reach of this court's injunctive power,
at least based on the nature of the pending action. Accordingly,
plaintiff's motion to compel is denied. Conclusion. For the foregoing
reasons, it is hereby ordered that plaintiff's motion of entry
of agreed order to compel LLC LLC to remove videos is denied.
Document entry 80. Done and ordered.
Okay. So, to me, this sounds like
probably regardless. I don't know. Man, it'd be cool if they
could just get the the judge to like rule on some of this stuff
or look at it, right? Like, is there nothing that makes a judge
go, "Okay, I'm not going to do the reply. You guys don't have
to reply to each other. Actually, you're just asking for something
that I can very easily immediately identify is not possible,
right? Because technically this was supposed to go through unopposed.
I believe if Pixie's if Pixie's team had not asked for Destiny
to pay for the legal fees of like engaging with Kiwi Farms and
getting it taken down, I think it was supposed to go through
unopposed. Based on this ruling, I have to believe that even
if it went through unopposed, it would still be denied. So, if
the lawsuit was against Solo for uploading, would they fall then
fall under C? No, I think they would fall under a the
if the lawsuit was against Solo for
Um Oh,
yeah. No, I think you'd get Solo to take it down with his account,
right?
I think that's what it would be. But I think if you wanted to
compel Kiwi Farms to take it down, I think you would have to
be suing Kiwi Farms or it would have to be somebody working in
concert with Kiwi Farms. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Okay. All right, man. Okay,
so there's one more document here and this is the big one.
Trying to like wake up right now.
Okay, this is it.
This is going to be the big one. So, a couple months ago, Pixie
or put in a what do you call it? She put in an a motion for a
preliminary injunction.
She sought a pre preliminary injunction and a TTRO against Destiny
for certain conduct. Okay.
Uh this is just the ruling on that. They had the whole evidentiary
hearing based on this. They introduced Abby as a like actual
witness in the case based on this and then eventually they modified
their initial complaint. Realized that this probably wasn't going
anywhere. So
we'll see. We'll see. All right. Order on plaintiff's motion
for preliminary Actually, hold on a second. Let me switch chairs.
Okay. All right. Order on plaintiff's motion for preliminary
injunction.
This matter is before the court on plaintiff Jane Doe's motion.
Oh, hold on.
Okay, there we go. This matter is before the court on plaintiff
Jane Doe's motion for preliminary injunction. Document entry
21. Defendant timely responded documentary entry 42 to which
plaintiff timely replied documentary 49. An evidentary hearing
was held on the motion. Accordingly, plaintiff's motion is right
for disposition. After careful review of the motion, response,
reply, relevant authority, and for the reasons discussed below,
plaintiff's motion is denied.
background. This case stems from what plaintiff alleges is defendant's
wrongful dissemination of a video of a nature. The video involving
both Ms. Do and Mr. Banell. Both plaintiff and defendant are
live streamers. Accordingly, plaintiff and defendant met online
on or before late 2019, uh approximately 2 years before September
12th, 2020. Okay, whatever. Their online friendship eventually
yielded discussions of a more intimate and ultimately nature.
These discussions included each sending the other videos of them
engaging in facts with the with others. The parties then met
in person in se on September 12th, 2020 and had a separate encounter
which was consensually recorded. It is here that the party's
allegations as to what became of the video steeply diverge. In
either April or October of 2022, defendant transmitted the video
to a friend of his on Discord rose.
Defendant alleges that since that date he has not shared or otherwise
transmitted the video to any other third party and will not do
so. Emphasis in original. This is his uh original testimony here.
Plaintiff alleges that defendant has shared the video with at
least one other individual beyond Rose ABMC documentary 12 at
4. Plaintiff further alleges that defendants's practice of hosting
explicit material on a Google Drive and sharing a link or links
to that Google Drive constitutes ongoing dissemination.
In any event, the video was uploaded to the website Kiwi Farms
on November 29th, 2024. The video was uploaded under the screen
name Solotin Leaks. Both parties allege that they did not consent
to the uploading of the video onto Kiwi Farms. Defendant, for
his part, alleges that he was the victim of revenge and suspects
it was someone with access to Rose's Discord chats.
The video was one among many involving defendant that were uploaded
to Kiwi Farms. Further, the video did not remain only on Kiwi
Farms and has been found on other sites that similarly host material
of a similar nature. Docu Entry 120 plaintiff and defendant both
alleged that they made overtures to have the video removed from
various sites. This is like just going to be a rundown of everything
they had to run like all the evidence, all the contentions from
both parties.
On January 22nd, 2025, plaintiffs council sent defendant a letter
entitled demand for preservation of evidence in matter of Jane
Dov. Steven Bedell. The letter advised defendant in writing of
the pendency of the present present action and including or and
included the following. You are hereby advised of your legal
obligation to preserve maintain prevents spoilation of and not
destroy evidence which in any way relates to this matter. Plaintiff
then filed this lawsuit on February 18th 2025
and on April 3rd 2025 plaintiff filed the motion presently before
us which requested to preliminary injunction for the following.
One, to enjoin Steven Benell from further sharing, distributing
or publishing the intimate images, videos, etc. uh uh videos
and or intimate information of the plaintiff. Two, compel Benell
to remove all publications of the videos and all messages between
him and plaintiff from all forms of public media
he controls either directly or indirectly. So, these two are
already being governed by another motion.
Number three is just a legal obligation he already has.
And number four is
retrieve all of this stuff. I think this is sort of understood
under like
he's basically said he's done this, right?
Which is to order defended to retrieve the messages he's deleted
and to cease and desist from destroying evidence. Oh, hold on.
Three is direct third parties. Oh, four is the spoliation one.
Sorry, four is the spoliation one. He's already legally required
to do this. Number four. Whoops. Three and four got swapped in
my head.
Um, this one's to do with spoliation. And number three was order
defendant to direct third parties in writing to remove all published
intimate images/v videos of plaintiff from any information or
and any information regarding plaintiff under their control.
So okay anybody that you could you could reach out to try to
get them to remove the video or anything related as well. Okay.
So that sets up basically um this is already ordered. These two
are going under a different um motion entirely. And number three
is
I actually don't know if number three is ever going to be handled
or not. Seems like number three was the previous one, right?
Trying to get people to Well, no, it's actually a little different.
I don't know. Number three is kind of standing on its own. Anyway,
at a subsequent hearing on April 4th, 2025, Judge Becca denied
plaintiff's request for a TTRO and subsequently referred the
remainder of plaintiff's motion for preliminary injunction to
the undersigned for dis
The court held an evidentiary hearing on the motion to address
the disputed uh disputed issues of fact presented by the briefing
on the motion applicable principles and law. The basis of injunctive
relief in the federal courts has always been irreparable harm
and inadequacy of legal remedies.
So basically the in irreparable harm is something that won't
be fixed by any legal means as well. like so so irreparable harm
here
would be something
unless you stop him from doing something I'm going to suffer
additional harm that can't be fixed right so unfortunately
I think in a lot of ways Pixie's entire case is about reputational
harm and although Desi's speech could cause further reputational
harm there's no reason to think that it's causing like harm in
a way that couldn't be made up for um be it more money or that
there wouldn't be another legal remedy to enjoin him from. Yeah.
Anyway,
so this is the basis for injunctive relief. To obtain a preliminary
injunction, a movement must demonstrate the following. Uh a one,
substantial likelihood of success on the merits of the underlying
case. Two, the movement will suffer irreparable harm in the absence
of an injunction. Three, the harm suffered by the movement in
the absence of an injunction would exceed the harm suffered by
the opposing party if the injunction is issued. and four, an
injunction would not to serve the public interest. Okay. In the
11th circuit, a preliminary injunction is an extraordinary and
drastic remedy not to be granted unless the movement clearly
established the burden of persuasion as to the four requisites.
So unless they're believably
proving all four of these things
and I think what what does Pixie have here? Substantial. So I
think
this is going to be in question the substantial likelihood purely
on the motion to dismiss. There's currently a motion to dismiss
there. If if that motion to dismiss goes through, I don't know
that this can really be evaluated. So, I would guess then they
would punt on this that she would suffer an irreparable harm
in the absence of an injunction. I think the issue for that one
is going to be that she filed the preliminary injunction motion
quite late. Three, the harm suffered by the movement in the absence
of an injunction would exceed the harm suffered by the opposing
party if the injunction was issued. I think she's kind of shown
this one. And for an injunction would not I think I think three
and four are fine. Legal Mindset has a 10-minute video covering
this. Yeah. And if I wanted a total
opinion, I would probably watch that video. But right now, I
don't want a total opinion on it. So, I'm going to not watch
that video right now. Going to actually read this myself. Yeah,
just saying. I By the way, I'm reading this on the fly and I
I actually think my opinion is more valid than his. I'm just
reading on the fly and trying to see what's going on like as
I'm watching this after already streaming for six hours. And
I still trust whatever I'm going to come away with this with
like far more highly than I I trust him. Thought you like law
tube legal mindset gets too many things too catastrophically
wrong to be trusted. He is horrible at this. Like he gets things
wrong constantly
and not things that you should get wrong as a lawyer, right?
Like I often have to go and look things up to figure out what's
going on. It's like he just makes assumptions and flies by the
seat of his pants and gets things wrong all the time.
And I don't even have like a reputation I need to uphold as some
sort of legal
He does anyway. Potentially criminal is fine. Yeah.
Well, I guess sorry. Potentially criminals been fine and like
the stuff I've watched. I'm sure he's got some
I just know that all of those people are super conservative.
I'm sure they've got some awful opinions on politics and stuff.
Anyway, we continue. Preliminary injunction is extraordinary.
Drastic remedy and drastic remedy. I need to show the what is
it? Burden of persuasion is the four requisites. Okay.
Because a preliminary injunction is an extraordinary and drastic
remedy. Its grant is the exception rather than the rule and plaintiff
must clearly carry the burden of persuasion. However, if the
movement is unable to establish a likelihood of success in the
merits, a court need a court need not consider the remaining
conditions prerequisite to injunctive relief. The goal of the
preliminary injunction is to prevent irreparable harm and to
preserve the district court's power to render a meaningful decision
after a trial on the
Okay. So, or a meaningful decision. Uh, okay. So, like basically
the other thing about an injunction is like
essentially with a preliminary injunction or a TTRO, it's like
I'm suing this person
to stop something bad from happening or or to fix an injury.
If you don't grant this injunctive relief, if you don't enjoin
them, I will be harmed in a way that at the end of the case,
you will not be able to make up to me. And I think for a lot
of this stuff,
it it just doesn't quite fit under the preliminary injunction
banner correctly.
As in, like, yes, Destiny, maybe you could argue that you're
going to be harmed if this person talks about you in some way,
but are you going to be harmed more than could be made up for
by like anything else? is is it harming you in a way that can't
be fixed later or wouldn't be
it's just like that that is a difficult thing to prove right
so like the idea of a preliminary injunction or a TTRO that I
would think of is like you are suing a company who let's say
you're suing a company who's infringing on your patent or something
right and they they basically announce they're going to like
publish it publicly some patented thing that like if it gets
published you'll you won't have any chance to earn any money
off of it right and it's like well I need you to join them from
from publishing that because obviously if you don't I'm suing
them to like get control of my patent back. I would be like it
won't matter if you get it back to me because it'll be over already,
right? Be something like that. Like basically they're going to
take an action. They're I want you to enjoin them from some behavior
that will make that will render this lawsuit moot. Like they
will destroy whatever thing I'm trying to gain control of or
trying to get out of this lawsuit. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Free specific.
That's another one. if you're arguing over ownership of a car
and the party in possession of the car was planning on exploding
it or something along these lines. It's like I'm going to I'm
going to suffer an irreparable harm if you don't fix this. And
I just say given those four bullet points again, those four bullet
points are that you can't um you can't talk about my messages.
You can't leak anything about my messages anymore or talk about
me. You can't um you need to get the video taken down. Video
taken down. And so you have to take the video down or any messages
about me down. you have to try to get the videos taken down.
And then number four was you have to stop destroying evidence.
It's like, okay, well,
I think destroying evidence is the only one that you could argue
is like an irreparable harm, maybe. And it's he's already enjoined
from that behavior. Like he's already legally compelled not to
behave that way. So I I don't know. Uh it says that these are
less likely than So what does it say? Extraordinary and drastic
remedy not to be granted unless the movement clearly establishes
everything. So it should be not the rule. should be the exception
rather than the rule. Yes, because it's a extraordinary and drastic
remedy. Its grant is the exception rather than the rule. Yeah,
I I would assume it's less likely. In any case,
these aren't even going to be the primary thing that I think
is going to be the problem as we go along. What we'll find is
what we'll find as we go along here, I believe, is that
the inadequacy of legal remedies is going to be the thing that
pops up. Knowing that Pixie's team already has motions filed
to handle some of the elements of this preliminary injunction
and had them filed like months ago, that sort of leans towards
telling us that, hey,
the the legal remedies are not inadequate. They're actually just
there and you could probably go to those, right? So, you took
a long time to file the preliminary injunction in the first place
and you're filing like motions to enjoin certain behavior that
aren't preliminary injunction motions. Okay, it seems like those
are just fine and you're not suffering irreparable harm. We're
we're just going to let you go take the other legal remedies
or try the other legal remedies. Okay. All right. We read this
goal of preliminary injunction is to prevent irreparable harm
to preserve the district court's power to render a meaningful
decision after a trial on its merits. The most compelling reason
in favor of granting a preliminary injunction is the need to
prevent the judicial process from being rendered futile by defendants's
action or refusal to act. And it's like, yeah, probably through
for all of those things, it's not going to except the spoilation
thing, it's not going to render the rest of the court case futile,
and the spoilation thing is already enjoined. When an injunction
does more than preserve the status quo, however, an even stronger
showing is required. A mandatory injunction, especially at the
preliminary stage of proceedings, should not be granted except
in rare instances in which the facts and law are clearly in favor
of the moving party. Mandatory injunctions are rarely issued
and interlocatory mandatory injunctions are even more rarely
issued and neither is except neither except upon or sorry and
neither except upon the clearest equitable grounds. So I think
this is saying
so I'm just going to wing this. I'm going to try it. This is
my interpretation. Latigious gamer if you're here you tell me
if you have a different interpretation. basically like
mandatorily
enjoining somebody from speaking like an interlocuatory
mandatory injunction
is extremely rare because of how it prejudices the rest of the
case
and it can't be granted except like in a way that shows that
you will not be the case over like basically I think a preliminary
mandatory injunction saying Destiny can't speak on this stuff
would probably be inappropriate unless it was like very clear
that it was required and I don't think it's going to be clear
that it was required. First, a party requesting a preliminary
injunction must generally show reasonable diligence or this three
Thus, a delay in seeking a preliminary injunction of even only
a few months, though not necessarily fatal, militates against
the finding of irreparable harm. So, this is an actual finding
in a US court that if you're delaying to file a preliminary injunction
for months, that's already going to work against the fact that
or the idea that you could suffer a reparable harm. If you were
suffering that kind of irreparable harm, you would file this
this paperwork like way earlier. Uh, yeah. Well, it's the exact
same thing. It's the exact same thing. So, Dustin Suggs asks,
okay, so basically it's like how they went after Pixie's attorney
early on for fighting on grounds the case should take care of
naturally. Yes, it's like that same
Uh indeed, the very idea of a preliminary injunction is premised
on the need for a speedy and urgent action to protect a plaintiff's
rights before a case can be resolved on its merits.
To that end, while the movement must meet all four elements required
to merit the issuance of a preliminary injunction, a showing
of irreparable injury is the sin quan uh sqanon of injunctive
relief.
Even if plaintiff establishes a likelihood of success on the
merits, the absence of a substantial likelihood of a reparable
injury would standing alone make preliminary injunctive relief
improper. So regardless of how likely she is to succeed on the
merits, it's like you still need something that can't be fixed
later, something that is going to happen that would stop the
court from actually
giving you the win in court like after the fact. Um, like if
I think something else you could enjoy, a good idea of what you
could enjoy in here is like if Destiny started like gambling
all of his money away, perhaps you could get an like uh some
kind of preliminary injunction on that on him like spending his
money in certain ways or he might need to set something aside,
right? You had evidence of him trying to spend all of his money
before it could be taken from him. Like something like that maybe
you could enjoin, I'm guessing. Okay.
Continuing the plaintiff's success in establishing a likelihood
it will prevail on the merits does not obiate the necessity to
show irreparable harm.
Okay. So even if you're going to be successful you have to show
alleged irreparable ah you need to show irreparable harm or that
irreparable harm is likely occurring. Such alleged irreparable
injury must be neither remote nor speculative but actual and
imminent. Accordingly, we will begin by analyzing plaintiff's
showing of irreparable harm. As described above, plaintiff commenced
this action on February 18th, 2025 and subsequently filed her
motion for a TTRO and preliminary injunction on April 2nd, 2025.
So like
what is this 3 months? 3 months 4 months after I guess you could
say after the initial leaks, like 5 months,
5 months, 6 months, 5 months. This matter, however, ultimately
stems from defendants's alleged sharing of the video several
years prior to the commencement of this action, whether only
with Rose or additional persons.
Defendant theorizes that it was a hack of Rose's Discord that
led to the leak of the video, and thus it's sub it's subsequently
being uploaded to Kiwi Farms on November 29th, 2024.
So from the allegations in plaintiff's timeline, even if we look
at only the closest incident to the present, the video being
uploaded to Kiwi Farms on November 29th, 2024, plaintiff waited
roughly 5 months to file her motion for preliminary injunction
and provided no convincing justification for the delay. That
fact alone suggests that plaintiff's alleged harm, even though
it may be tangible and compensible at the conclusion of litigation,
is not irreparable as that term is applied in the context of
the preliminary injunction motion. So
he's saying basically the strongest indicator we have is that
it took you 5 months from the videos originally being posted
to seek a legal remedy to them being on that site or seeking
in any way to get them removed from that site. That likely leads
us to believe that you believe that you yourself think that like
the milk is spilt and there's not really a way to fix that like
the cat's out of the bag on that front. And so while you are
very likely like harmed in a tangible way that you can be compensated
for, it is not something that's irreparable, is not something
that is getting worse or will get worse if we do not take immediate
injunctive relief or if we do not immediately enjoin behavior
on your behalf. A meme someone made for me. What is this? Okay,
I don't I don't understand, but cool. So let's see here. affirming
uh C real LLC 840 affirming denial of preliminary injunctive
injunction where plaintiff failed to offer any explanation for
its 5-month delay and the record did not indicate any justification
thereof absent compelling reasons shown otherwise as extended
delay in moving for relief to address irreparable harm undermines
that burden in the first instance university so they cited a
case the university delayed a seeking a preliminary injunction
for nearly 6 months after it initiated this action in January
2022 and when it did eventually file its motion for preliminary
injunction. It failed to offer any reason for the delay and relied
almost exclusively on evidence that was available to it when
it was when it filed its complaint. Importantly, plaintiff's
request for a TTRO was denied for similar reasons at the April
4th, 2025 hearing. In fact, plaintiffs council even agreed that
most of the damage has already been done.
That's the thing is like if it's spilled milk, then you don't
need a preliminary injunction. If you want to if you want to
have something happen, you want a motion for like, oh, Destiny
shouldn't be talking about you anymore, like you can file that
motion if you want, but there's like a there are different legal
avenues for it. I thought Pixie talked with Destiny about him
getting it removed at the time. There are logs that say that.
There just isn't significant evidence of Destiny doing that,
right? Destiny has that oneline email to null that was like,
"Hey, can you remove videos of me from your website? Thanks."
So at 63, this is um this is the transcript from the first hearing
for the TTRO,
which accords with the fact that three of the four elements of
plaintiff's requested preliminary injunction are targeted at
defendants's alleged publication and/or distribution of intimate
images and videos or related information, i.e. the video, which
is the crux of the plaintiff's claims. As to the fourth item
of plaintiff's requested preliminary injunction addressing alleged
expolation of relevant evidence, plaintiffs council then proceeded
to explain at the April 4th, 2025 hearing that the ongoing issue
is that we keep receiving evidence of destruction of evidence.
We are trying to compile enough evidence to file a motion for
spoliation.
Uh it is now October of 2025 and there is no such motion on the
docket despite there be that being the thenexisting ongoing harm
plaintiff was ostensibly seeking to stop. But even putting aside
for a moment the plaintiff's council's statement at the TTRO
hearing, the the allegations and plaintiff's motion as to uh
an imminent risk of further non-consensual disclosures of intimate
images of herself by Banell and further humiliation from the
same also do not convince us of ongoing harm. As in I'm guessing
I'm guessing this is like so
let's do an imminent risk. So if there were I think this is saying
something that's like it seems crazy but I understand it in like
a purely legal sense. I think it's saying that listen even if
even if he was like about to post this again
you have that's not like an immediate harm like
we can't do you have to enjoin somebody it's like if the court
is going to enjoin somebody from murder it's like no they're
already not supposed to murder like I don't I don't have to do
a legal injunction for that also do not convince us of ongoing
harm yes okay
so it's like it's not an ongoing harm that is continuing it's
like something that could happen
In her motion, plaintiff claims that it is the imminent risk
of further non-consentual disclosures by defendant that creates
ongoing harm sufficient to merit a pre preliminary injunction.
But albeit very distressing, the video at the center of this
dispute is online. Plaintiff acknowledges as much in her amended
complaint, citing several websites that are currently hosting
or have hosted and then removed the video. See these docket entries?
Despite efforts to have the video removed from different sites,
they are still there and available to the public. So my humiliation
is ongoing and although not the focus of plaintiff's actual claims
or in large part the party's briefing to the extent any communications
between the parties are publicly available including several
exhibits submitted in support of the party's briefings see these
examples those two are already online and further both plaintiff
and defendant have engaged in online commentary regarding this
case including as to their version of the events and/or purposes
see these examples we do not doubt plaintiff's testimony that
she is distraught because of these events document entry 211
F4 to the contrary we find her testimony fully credible in this
regard. But as her council stated at the TTRO hearing, the damage
has already been done as to the video and related statements
and was as of the time of the TTRO hearing on April 4th, 2025.
There is then no irreparable injury, a need for speedy or a need
for speedy and urgent action that would trigger the issuance
of a preliminary injunction here. So I think I think this is
probably Pixie's team Pixie team's fault. they're kind of like
poor
but I think what she was kind of concerned about was Destiny
publishing more like sexs of them and stuff
and I guess she felt like that was humiliating and it seems like
the judge doesn't have a good idea of that, right? So, so he's
saying what is the TLDDR so far? the TLDDR so far is although
yeah you're like up and yeah you have a real case and yeah this
is like and we believe you it doesn't sound like so the it doesn't
sound like this is the correct legal avenue for any of the remedies
you're seeking. Yeah, it just doesn't seem like it's the correct
legal avenue for any of the like the remedies you're seeking.
If you want him to stop destroying evidence, well, he's already
enjoined from that behavior. He's already gotten a notice saying
you cannot legally do this. You're legally compelled to maintain
archives of this evidence, right? He would have continued sharing
her videos if she didn't sue. Yes,
But like that's already illegal. And unless you have some like
actual statement showing that he plans to post more videos. Like
if he was threatening to post more videos, maybe you could enjoying
some kind of behavior there. But I don't even see like that's
not there either. I think she was worried about him releasing
more DMs between them. That would be embarrassing. I think that's
it. And again, I don't think any of this is saying I haven't
seen it say that like there's no reason she can't seek other
injunctive relief or sorry that she can't seek other relief or
that she can't do other things. But this it's just that a preliminary
injunction itself is not the vehicle by which she makes that
uh that case. Okay. Okay. We read all this. Additionally, mere
injuries, however substantial, in terms of money, time and energy
necessarily expended in the absence of an injunction are not
enough. So just because
like just because you might suffer injuries or whatever in terms
of money or time, it's like it's about whether or not you can
make that back, right? The possibility that adequate compensatory
or other corrective relief will be available at a later date
in the ordinary course of litigation weighs heavily against a
claim of irreparable harm. So unfortunately what they're saying
here is your primary goal is likely to get money back from this
guy. Even if like his commentary is going to [__]
with
if you have like a a case with merit to it, you're actually just
going to be able to take money from him based on that, right?
Like if he was if he was harming you additionally throughout
the course of this case and we can find that money would be the
sort like the solution there as well. So there's now a confidentiality
agreement and protective order that governs discovery in this
case, including how to handle confidential information. Should
plaintiff discover evidence of spoliation, she's able to file
a rule 73 rule 37 motion or otherwise request relief from the
court. Plaintiff has also attested that she has made efforts
to have the video removed. See documentary entry 491
paragraph 17. And plaintiff has already filed several motions
in this case seeking relief from the court as to among other
things the video being hosted on a third party site. Public statements
by the parties
council. Okay, hold on.
I should probably start looking at a couple of these little uh
footnotes here. We have the footnote going on. We had six here.
Plaintiff does plaintiff does allege that during the only time
she and Benell had relations, he recorded videos plural. But
as to the risk of ongoing harm regarding defending continued
to share videographic material, the declarations to which plaintiff
cites allege only that he shared or sought to share the video.
Further, while plaintiff's operative complaint includes the videos
in her claims, the allegations regard defendants sharing of the
video, it is unclear if some references to the plural form are
even intentional as they would seem to contradict prior submitted
exhibits. Contrast this thing with Hannah Brook.
Uh oh. Hannah Brookke, a follower of Banel contacted plaintiff
and informs her that even after the
video was publicized on November 29th, 2024, Destiny/Banell offered
to send the videos to her. emphasis added. On or about November
2024, I became aware that a explicit video that included Destiny
and another streamer, Pixie, had been published on the internet.
On January 9th, 2025, at 1:36 p.m., Destiny offered to send me
the video. O, I mean, I guess now that is leaked. A discrepancy
aside, there's no actual indication that even if there were an
offer to send multiple videos that they would include plaintiff
one, the unsworn statement specifically references the video
singular. And two, her plaintiff's own allegations or sorry,
per plaintiff's own allegations, defendant had other videos of
encounters not involving her. See these
added.
So, this is saying that even though you had the Hannah testimony
there, it's not guaranteed that you were like that he was directing
to the video of you, right? Which is reasonable, but also like
was probably directing to a page that included that. Yeah. How
can she win? Judge said it happened before the law existed. Judge
didn't say that.
Um, literally the judge, the last thing the judge said and including
in this motion, I believe the judge actually makes it clear that
there that is an unanswered question in this
in this actual thing. He says it's on April 4th or October 10th
or April 10th or October 4th rather.
So,
judge didn't say that yet unless I missed it, but even then there's
other other parts to this. So, whoa, whoa. Where are we going
from here? We are on to this guy.
Public statements by the parties and their council. No, no, no.
I need to start from the beginning of the sentence. Give me a
second. Plaintiff has already filed several motions in this case
seeking relief from the court as to among other things the videos
being hosted on a third party site, public statements by the
parties and their council. Do entry 84 and recourse for alleged
sanctionable statements and actions by defendant. Docket entry
113. We raised these motions and actions not to comment on their
merits, but because by doing so, plaintiff is actively seeking
avenues of other corrective relief for alleged issues that track
her injunction request, further weighing against her claim that
she is facing irreparable harm and that cannot be ameliated by
any other means. So, this is going back to what I said before.
It's basically like, okay, and this to me signals that Pixie's
team knew that, oh, we filed a motion for preliminary injunction,
but now we like we started talking over it and it's like, oh,
this probably wasn't the way to do this, right? And so they started
filing the individual motions to address this through other legal
means. Okay. Uh, and to the point of compensatory relief, Samson
415 US and 90 plaintiff herself has acknowledged on social media
that a primary aim of the lawsuit is inherently financial. Yeah,
obviously. But I like that. I think this is the one that Destiny
posted to social media himself. It was like, look, he could see
through her and it's like I don't know if you know this, but
the point of every single civil case ever essentially is financial
relief in some way or another, right?
Like that is that is so many civil cases. That's like every civil
case. You're suing somebody to get money back for some harm you
suffered. Yeah.
He's like, "Oh, I I showed it. I guys, I showed it. She only
wants money." It's like, well, that is probably the only She
can't get back her privacy.
Cat's out of the bag there, buddy.
So, what does she say? I don't know what you're specifically
referring to, but Steven is a multi-millionaire, and I want him
to lose so much money as a result of this that every time he
thinks of the word nude, he cringes at his mistake. I truly believe
if the cost isn't high enough, he will do this again. My goal
here is not public humiliation or is not public humiliation of
Steven or even all the money in the world. It's him receiving
such a financial hit penalty that he will pro he will permanently
learn his lesson.
So I guess you could say in a lot of ways Pixie's already won.
Thus plaintiff's alleged injury could by her own words be addressed
by way of legal remedy. So by her own words, she's looking for
the money.
Show me the money.
Accordingly, and for the foregoing reasons, we do not find that
plaintiff will suffer an irreparable injury unless an injunction
ensues or an injunction
uh as the absence of substantial likelihood of a reparable injury
would standing alone make preliminary injunctive relief improper.
We are empowered to deny plaintiff's motion solely on this finding.
But as to plaintiff's likelihood of success on the merits, we
note that there is an outstanding question of whether this court
has subject matter jurisdiction over this case. See docket entry
132 uh the 12B1 motion to dismiss on grounds of lack of summary
lack of subject matter jurisdiction
order allowing leave to amend complaint and discussing jurisdictional
complexity. So plaintiff also adds that she has made a primmaascia
case as to her claim under 15USC section 6851.
But that would be mistaken if plaintiff cannot show in due course
that the conduct is alleged is indeed covered by the statute
and were it not covered because plaintiff's assertion of federal
question jurisdiction hinges on the acceptability of 15 USC 6851.
It is possible that we do not have subject subject matter jurisdiction
over plaintiff's case. At this stage, we cannot agree that plaintiff
has demonstrated the likelihood of prevailing on even one cause
of action because if 15 USC6851
does not cover the alleged conduct, plaintiff necessarily cannot
prevail on that claim. And two, if we do not have subject matter
jurisdiction over plaintiff's case, we cannot opine on whether
plaintiff would prevail on her state law claims. Ultimately,
as with irreparable harm, we would be empowered to deny plaintiff's
motion solely on this finding. as well. If the movement is unable
to establish a likelihood of success in the merits, a court need
not consider the remaining conditions prerequisite to injective
relief.
So they're saying that basically until this question until the
question of subject matter jurisdiction is answered, you cannot
say you have like a mer
despite whatever else is happening, if you don't have a if you
can't sue in this court, like you basically everything's invalid.
And so it's impossible for you to prove this until the motion
to dismiss goes through. Right
now, I will say the funny thing about this is is if people are
saying that this is the court saying that there's no merit to
the case, I would I would kind of laugh at that because the second
I would laugh at that
if the motion to dismiss is denied, which is expected by basically
everybody I've seen look at this, including Destiny and most
EGers. Most people expect the motion to dismiss to be denied.
And if it is if it is denied then that's saying they do have
subject matter jurisdiction and I
this entire thing goes away and suddenly they they have like
a case with merit to it right to me that's how it looks. Anyway,
nonetheless as to the final two elements of the preliminary injunction
analysis plaintiff has not shown that she under the circumstances
is at risk of irreparable harm as a result of any alleged
wait did I go through this? Yeah. Yeah. any alleged continued
dissemination of her intimate visual depictions and private information
or as alleged in the hearing dispolation of evidence and thus
any injury would not outweigh the damage of unduly imposing an
injunction. Further, as to the public interest, plaintiff argues
that congressional intent behind 15 USC6851
creates a public policy against non-consentual sharing of intimate
images. Even if true, plaintiff's argument is inapplicable if
the alleged conduct is not covered under US uh 15 USC 6851.
Yeah. So
like all we need to really look at here
is the what do you call it? The lack of a proof of a reparable
harm being caused.
I think the the likelihood of succeeding on the merits that will
be answered by the motion to dismiss. If the motion to dismiss
is successful, then yeah, there wasn't a merit to the case. And
if it's unsuccessful, then I think all of that stuff kind of
reverses in here and they go, "Well, even though even though
you have a case with merit to it, you still haven't proven irreparable
harm." Yeah.
In some plaintiff has not clearly established the burden of persuasion
as to the four requisites. Promotion for preliminary injunction
is denied, but that denial is of course without prejudice to
the ultimate adjudication of the case, which may or may not require
permanent injunctive relief if legally sound.
Conclusion. For the fourgoing reasons, plaintiff's motion for
preliminary injunction is denied. The motion is adjudicated by
order as the motion is largely denied for procedural grounds
and not on the ultimate merits. Okay. Adjudicated by order as
the motion is largely denied for procedural grounds and not on
the ultimate merits. Okay,
cool. Uh adjudicated by order. What does that mean when it's
like a like they're saying I've signifies that a final decision
has been made and officially issued in a formal or administrative
legal process resolving a claim or dispute. decision notice an
adjudication order applies legal rules to specific circumstances
and settles the matter such as an application for benefit.
All right.
That's I thought there might be something else to that. Largely
denied for procedural grounds, but injunctive relief generally
is addressed by a magister judge via report and recommendation
because a litigant would be entitled to denovo review from the
district judge if such review is sought. The entry of this order
does not foreclose any party from appealing this order, which
would be then be treated as a report and recommendation by the
district judge under local magistrate
Parties retain the right to uh to denovo review if such an appeal
is filed.
It means adjudicated by order as opposed to just recommending
a decision to the district court judge. Okay. Yeah. Sorry. If
I if I kept reading latigious gamer, I would have seen that,
right? So like, oh, we're actually saying this is like an order
for the the case itself, but technically if they want to appeal
it to the district judge, then it's just a recommendation and
the judge will handle the appeal themselves.
Is further ordered that as to any links or uh links to images
or online documents
and on a going uh going forward basis, the references linked
to must be included as exhibits to filings. For security reasons,
the court will not open random links to eg to examples imager
or Google drive. Should a party believe any such exhibit should
be sealed, they may file a motion seeking leave of the court
to file it under seal as with any other filing or exhibit. Done
and ordered in chambers at Miami, Florida this 6th day of October
2025. Damn. Okay. Yeah. So, in conclusion, I think the only thing
we get out of this is that
uh there's no proof of like an ongoing harm, ongoing irreparable
harm,
which here doesn't mean she's not being harmed. They go, "Oh,
yeah. Well, we understand that you like you've been wronged and
that there's like pain there and all of that, but cats out of
the bag, right? And that's the only thing you're citing. And
anything else you site in terms of expoliation, like they're
already enjoined from that and there's not even like solid proof
of that. So
yeah, it just seems like the preliminary injunction is the wrong
way to go. I think this is the thing to me that makes me think
like, oh, this is all not like that big a deal is that Pixie
and her team seem to have gone and filed multiple document entries
like with specific motions to accomplish the goals of this preliminary
injunction just through other legal means. Yeah, they actually
say multiple times they're not commenting on the merits of the
case, right? There is a there's a different like the motion to
dismiss right now is going to comment is like going to be their
response on the merits of the case. Yeah. So I I don't see this
as like a major win because I don't think most of the things
here I even expected to be
like passed. I thought most I think I thought three out of four
of these things would be denied
personally.
I thought maybe the thing they could kind of get through is a
gag order on Destiny commenting on Pixie. I thought that was
the thing they might have a shot at. And now that's being done
as a public as a protective order, like a motion for protective
order governing public statements or something. Let me I could
pull that up on the
Yeah. So that that would be like what this is covered by. This
is from when is this? June 2nd,
right? So four months ago this was filed to get a good idea of
how far behind the judges are on on ordering anything in this
case.
So the injunctive relief or sorry the yeah the preliminary injunction
I forget when this was filed
the the motion the original motion was it like April April I
believe. So this was in April we just got the order 6 months
later from the preliminary junction filed in April and now this
is like superseding it. So 2 months later and 4 months ago they
filed this motion for protective order governing public commentary
by trial participants. Everything sought in the first element,
the thing that I thought they might have a shot on, is going
to be handled through this. I still don't I don't know if this
will go through either, although I think uh Desi's been endeavoring
to make sure it does with some of his public commentary, but
we will see. I I don't know. I I actually kind of want to go
look at the what is it?
Uh I want to look at that Destiny tweet again because I don't
know what he thought was like nuclear here. Now I I actually
don't even there was like oh that pixie was seeking money.
What is this one as the fourth item? Uh plaintiffs council then
proceed to explain April 4th. The ongoing issues keep seeing
destruction of evidence. They haven't sought anything. I think
this is just like
yeah they they believe that things are being deleted. So, what
what I think the evidence was, just to be clear, was people who
had had messages with Destiny were saying, "My messages were
deleted."
So, they had like a bunch of people saying, "Oh, he deleted all
this stuff. He deleted all this stuff." And I think they were
saying, "Well, we don't think he should be deleting all this
stuff."
And now I think they've also kind of had meet and confers. And
the judge said, "Well, we have to let him delete like the videos
because obviously
obviously you don't want the videos to stay in whatever place
where they could be re-shared, right?" But he deleted all of
his messages. So, I think that's what they were referring to.
Maybe they just jumped the gun on this one.
In any case, he's not allowed to delete evidence. He's already
legally barred from doing
So, I do like Hold on, hold on. I do like that. Um, Destiny point
post this as like a major dunk, but this is literally the same
judge, the magistrate judge with the same like little snipe at
Pixie's team that he took at Destiny's team. At Destiny's team,
they were like, "Hey, just so you know, he he said something
like they've once again brought up the the subject matter jurisdiction
thing, yet they still have failed to ever file a motion to dismiss,
right? They're just being like the judge was being snipy at him.
Now the judge is doing the same kind of sniping at Pixie. like,
yeah, they they filed this, but like why hasn't she filed a motion
on this exact topic?
I think it's I think it's funny that he sees that as a win when
it the judge directed that at his team first.
So, from the allegations and plaintiff's timeline, even if we
look at only the closest incident, plaintiff waited roughly 5
months to file her motion for preliminary injunction and provided
no convincing justification for the delay.
Yeah.
Yep. That was procedurally bad. The judge is obviously a KFR.
Um, yeah, I guess so.
I think this is like totally fine to point out. I just don't
understand. This is like zero comments on the merits of the case.
It's like to me, doesn't that seem concerning that like with
no comment on the merits of the case, Destiny like presents this
and he's like, "We won. We won. Oh, you're so brutal to them."
I don't know. It feels It feels a little strange to me that he
would celebrate this one so hard. It's like, dude, are your wins
so
so thin on the ground? Is it so rare that you get a W that you
got to celebrate this one that hard? Yeah. So, in any case, I
think Pixie would have liked if these things got ruled in her
favor. Obviously, I think the motion to compel KF to take it
down is a bigger one. Um, probably just would be like a thing
to get off of her mind. But yeah, for the preliminary injunction,
she would have wanted this passed, but I think they basically
already knew that it wasn't going to get passed
and they'd moved appropriately after the fact. Yeah, IMO knows
things aren't really impactful W's. He's trying to optic max.
Yeah, I'm saying I'm just I'm laughing about it. I realize we
all know it's just signaling to his audience, right? It's very
funny.
You cover the food shops tweet.
Uh, probably not. It's like um Yeah, probably not. Yeah, it's
just one of those things where it's like they're not I don't
know. They they always do the thing where they like won't talk,
but they want to comment.